mientras más de 4 años y medio de
cautiverio llegó la libertad para la
hermana gloria cecilia narváez este
sábado la monja colombiana fue liberada
por los yihadistas que la secuestraron
en febrero de 2017
mercedes autor agradezco a las
autoridades malienses al presidente a
todas las autoridades malienses por todo
el esfuerzo que han hecho para
liberarnos que dios los bendiga mi dios
los bendiga mal y que tiene que venirse
que debe venir y malin
narváez había estado trabajando como
misionera cerca de la frontera de mali
con burkina faso cuando fue retenida y
secuestrada por militantes de una
alianza yihadista vinculada a al qaeda
en la región del sahel los detalles y
las condiciones de liberación siguen sin
esclarecerse las autoridades malienses
describieron su liberación como el
resultado de años de esfuerzos
combinados de varios servicios de
inteligencia que han tenido reuniones a
nivel mundial
con embajadores de varios países
europeos pero también de países
africanos
siempre en el ánimo de buscar la
liberación sana y salva de nuestro
compatriota
apoyado por las fuerzas francesas y de
la onu mal y luchas de 2012 contra un
movimiento insurgente islamista los
secuestros para pedir rescate se han
convertido en una fuente de financiación
clave para los yihadistas en los últimos
años varios occidentales permanecen
cautivos en calidad de rehenes en la
región entre ellos el periodista francés
oliver du wei secuestrado hace seis
meses